launch of the shenzhou 16 spacecraft and
another milestone in China's ambitious
Space Program the three-person crew
includes a civilian for the first time
Academic Way haitau who was serving as
the team's Aerospace Systems specialist
the carrier rocket has launched the
shenzhou 16 manned spacecraft to the
predetermined orbit the solar panels are
extended and functioning normally I
declared the launch mission a success
the men will replace the crew from a
previous gender Mission and will live
aboard the Tian gong space station
orbiting Earth for five months
their tasks include maintaining
equipment spacewalks and conducting
scientific experiments in quantum theory
relativity and space-time so space
station is basically a huge laboratory
and it's a laboratory that's going to be
increasingly filled with a variety of
experiments and Technologies from around
the world and so that is intended to um
you know so the reason why there's a
civilian is that civilian is a scientist
an academic and you need somebody with
the skill and the experience and the
knowledge of how to operate maintain you
know delicate equipment and that can't
be done with people usually from
military background
all astronauts on previous missions have
been part of the people's Liberation
Army the space program is a source of
national pride it's remained a priority
throughout the pandemic and despite a
slowing economy
completed late last year the Tian gong
is a crucial step in China's long-term
space goals including putting a crude
mission on the Moon by 2030 and
eventually hosting tourists and
astronauts from other countries
but there are concerns about links to
the military
most launchers to date have had
government or military purposes
the United States excluded China from
the International Space Station in 2011
and banned it from working with NASA due
to security concerns China's
achievements are challenging U.S
dominance in Space the Pentagon predicts
that it could surpass NASA's
capabilities as early as 2045. right now
though Washington is investing more than
Beijing and it has a much larger network
of international academic and Commercial
partners Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing